[Music]
therapy dog teams have re-emerged across
the valley bringing smiles through
wagging tails to those in need
throughout the pandemic therapy dog
teams with michael's angel paws have
been visiting friends and staff at
david funeral homes henderson hospitals
and a number of senior citizen centers
bringing happiness to the hearts of
countless individuals there are nearly
350 therapy dog teams with this
organization
the joy they share goes beyond the
therapy visits however
as the organization also has an
assistance dog program
and volunteers were able to surprise a
veteran with a custom motorcycle
sidecar for her service dog hope
our assistant dog program we work with
different individuals
and we pair them up either with a dog or
they have a dog and then we work with
those teams to create
that partnership with that individual
who needs a specific need
michael's angel pause supports a number
of veteran associations across the
valley
the original sinners motorcycle club did
reach out to michael angel pauls to help
make this happen that's the veteran
there and there is her service dog hope
so they are a wonderful organization